Yannick Moré Saint-Brévin lespins
Vincent jeamb-brin lae les roses anne-
Françoise piedalu plourescamp ce sont
nos maires nos élus les symboles de
notre République tous victimes de
violence et d'attaque indiges parce que
les maires parce que les élus sont
dévoués au service de leurs concitoyens
et de l'intérêt général nos maères sont
réunis cette semaine à Paris pour le
105e congrès des maères sur le thème
commune attaquée République menacée dans
nos circonscriptions ils nous font
monter régulièrement un sentiment
d'empêchement et d'impuissance des élus
ils craignent la violence sur leur
mairie leur permanence leur domicile et
même envers leurs famillees ils
dénoncent la haine en ligne et les
menaces et alertent sur ce qu'ils
appellent la fatigue républicaine 40
démissions par mois et le sentiment pour
les maires de France qui tiennent
congrès que l'État les ignore que l'État
quelquefis les méprises un mépris qui se
traduit par l'absence notable du
président Macron à cette rencontre de
tous ceux qui sont le cœur battant de la
République tous les jours nos élus sont
engagés sur le terrain pour répondre aux
exigences de l'État qui s'accumule et
trop souvent nos élus locaux sont
empêchés parfois humiliés souvent
enququiné plutôt qu'accompagné pourtant
les maires tiennent la baraque France
gilets jaune covid inflation émeut les
maires n'ont pas manqué face aux crises
ils sont rester à porter d'engueulade
sans disposer des moyens pour répondre
au mots de nos concitoyens et des outils
pour recoudre une public fracturé 3500
maires sont désormais dans le dispositif
alarme élu les 36000 maires devraient y
être avec les services de Monsieur le
Gard des saau nous avons avec Monsieur
le Gard saau apporté notre contribution
au travail qu'a fait l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat pour que ce soit
les mêmes sanctions pour les
dépositaires de l'autorité publique et
les élus de la République le texte sera
publié complètement au début de l'année
2024 pour que les tribunaux puissent
condamner fermement les attaques contre
les élus et nous devons continuer à
former les policiers et les gendarmes
plus de 5000 aujourd'hui c'est le cas
des procureurs de la République qui je
sais rencontre partout arrondissement
par arrondissement les procureurs de la
République les sous-préfets les préfets
les élus ce qui touche madame la députée
les maires c'est la crise de l'autorité
au sein de notre société et les
violences contre les élus sont les mêmes
que contre les gendarmes que contre les
policiers que contre les enseignants que
contre les personnels qui sont ceux des
SAP pompiers ou des médecins c'est ceux
qui représent la République on devrait
tous être d'accord sur ça et la mission
que vous fait à Monsieur Jumel sera êre
par la première ministre et par le
Président de la République